il n'y aura quasiment pas eu débat dans
cette finale du tournoi future de
plaisir la tête de série numéro une
christopher et man menait pourtant 3
jeux à 2 dans le premier set avant de
voir son compatriote revenir et briquet
la suite est sans appel 6 3 6 0 le score
final yannick mertens en poche un
deuxième succès d'affilée en deux ans
sur le court plaisir ouah je pense que
mon niveau même toute la semaine était
très très bon donc je savais que je
pouvais bien joué ici parce que j'avais
je l'avais déjà fait l'année passée
j'avais gagné ici aussi donc je me
sentais bien je me sentais confiant et
mais bon après il faut toujours le
confirmer quoi et c'est jamais facile
mais je pense que je les ai faites très
bien quoi une finale qui s'est réglée en
moins de deux heures yannick mertens a
profité d'un adversaire fatigué et
auteur notamment de cinq doubles fautes
il ya eu qu'un seul joueur sur le
terrain c'est le jeune mertens qui a
qui a vraiment dominé de la tête et des
pieds si je puis dire son adversaire ça
a été un peu décevant quand je pensais
qu'il y allait avoir un peu plus de deux
combats peu plus de beaux points c'est
comme ça le public lui était au rendez
vous plus de 100 personnes ont assisté à
la finale du tournoi future classé en 6e
catégorie des compétitions de tennis
mondial
c'est une finale qui est quand même
assez importante parce que c'est le
tournoi le plus important je pense dans
l'ain dans le département je joue dans
ce club et je voulais voir une belle
finale et mes enfants sont ramasseurs de
balles en plus donc
finaliste également en double yannick
mertens a gravi quelques places au
classement atp ce lundi 23 septembre ils
étaient 400 17e joueur mondial